cuando las bombas callan queda l4 nador
de una ciudad en ruinas después de 11
días de ataques la reconstrucción de la
golpeada franja de gaza podría llevar
años o incluso décadas pocas horas
después del alto el fuego escenas
impactantes en la ciudad de gaza se
necesitan años para la reconstrucción y
décadas y no se levanta el bloqueo debe
detenerse el ciclo de destrucción y
reconstrucción los primeros envíos de
ayuda humanitaria llegan a cuentagotas
al sitiado enclave sumado a las pérdidas
humanas y los bombardeos israelíes
golpearon instalaciones gubernamentales
estaciones eléctricas sistemas de agua y
alcantarillado
los costos materiales son millonarios al
menos 800 edificios fueron destruidos y
más de 10 mil resultaron dañados en la
última ofensiva también unas 300
instalaciones esenciales fueron atacadas
50 escuelas y 22 hospitales no estoy de
acuerdo con esta tregua qué significa
esta tregua hemos vuelto a nuestras
casas y no tenemos un lugar donde
sentarnos no tenemos agua no tenemos
electricidad no tenemos camas no tenemos
nada toma el desafío de la
reconstrucción pasa por encontrar los
fondos
antes de los ataques la agencia de la
onu para los refugiados ofrecía
asistencia a 14 millones de gazatíes
pero la ayuda internacional ha
disminuido en los últimos años egipto
promedio 500 millones de dólares también
eeuu planea estar al frente en la
reconstrucción de gaza y apeló a una
solución de cara al futuro
no hay ningún cambio en mi compromiso
con la seguridad de israel punto ningún
cam en absoluto
pero te diré en lo que si hay un cambio
el cambio es que tenemos historia
necesitamos la solución de dos estados
es la única respuesta la única respuesta
es la reconstrucción de gaza se ve
comprometida por el hecho de que la
mayoría de gobiernos occidentales
consideran a hamas gobernante en la
franja como un grupo terrorista